[Música]
las tardes
yo creo que todos ustedes van a querer
oír cómo funciona el cerebro durante la
resiliencia y cómo podemos ser más
resilientes en la vida
el cerebro es uno de los sistemas más
complejos sofisticados y extraordinarios
que hasta ahora tenemos conocimiento
el cerebro ha transformado el mundo
cuenta con 100
billones de neuronas
tiene 100 interconexiones 100 trillones
de interconexiones pesa tan solo 3
libras y consume 20% de la energía del
organismo
los cambios
en el mundo y los avances de la
tecnología
han llevado a qué
se introduzcan
cosas como la inteligencia artificial la
robótica los algoritmos y todos estos
sistemas en sí están compitiendo con el
mismo cerebro
la competencia mediante todos estos
sistemas
ha llevado a que el cerebro tenga que
cambiar tenga que adaptarse tenga que
crear nuevas conexiones para adaptarse a
este mundo nuevo que será muy distinto
se calcula que para el año 2050 el mundo
será otro y el cerebro también habrá
tenido que cambiar muchísimo para
adaptarse quizás de los cambios más
importantes que se están llevando a cabo
con las nuevas tecnología son en salud
y en educación por ejemplo
en salud qué pasa con la medicina
actualmente nosotros los médicos debemos
pacientes y estos pacientes nos dan una
información nosotros
procesamos esa información y damos un
diagnóstico qué va a pasar en el futuro
en el futuro un paciente en una zona
rural podrá tomar su teléfono
inteligente suministra una información
importante a una central robótica y esa
central va a llegar a cruzar todas estas
variables toda esta información y va a
dar un diagnóstico preciso
en negocios se va a cambiar y en
educación yo creo que se vendrán los
cambios más importantes las
universidades los colegios van a tener
que ser otra cosa
miremos por ejemplo qué pasa en
educación y que hemos aprendido de cómo
funciona el cerebro
tenemos que aprender
cómo funciona el cerebro es importante
para enseñar y es importante para
estudiar como memorizamos nosotros los
textos que se nos ponen en un colegio o
en una universidad utilizamos la
repetición
muchos repiten y repiten las tablas de
multiplicar para aprenderse las podemos
subrayar
y podemos desarrollar preguntas de lo
que queremos aprender los dos primeros
sistemas les quiero decir que están
obsoletos fijan un conocimiento que dura
horas o días y desaparece repetir y
repetir no sirve subrayar si yo
desarrollo preguntas al subrayar lo
subrayado me va a servir pero de lo
contrario el conocimiento es muy efímero
va a durar muy poco tiempo y muchos de
nuestros estudiantes estudian así y
memorizan así
veamos un núcleo que es importantísimo
en el aprendizaje y en la educación su
núcleo muy pequeño en lo profundo del
cerebro se llama el núcleo accumbens el
núcleo accumbens es un núcleo que maneja
la recompensa este núcleo es importante
por ejemplo en drogadicción
y el núcleo acumbens lo ayuda a usted a
muchas cosas de recompensa que lo
satisfacen usted va a un restaurante
bueno se come una buena comida y se
siente muy contento se siente feliz esa
recompensa la edad el núcleo acumbens
usted por ejemplo va a un concierto hay
una música muy linda a una orquesta
maravillosa
y siente mucha satisfacción se siente
muy contento con eso pues venga les
cuento qué pasa con el aprendizaje y por
qué tenemos que conocer el cerebro en
los colegios los profesores tienen que
motivar al niño
el niño tiene que estar motivado el niño
tiene que ser exitoso el niño tiene que
ver que aprende fácil que contesta a los
exámenes bien que entiende cuando un
niño se le presenta una clase y en la
entiende y lo motivan y quisiera
volverlo a abrir está actuando el núcleo
acumbens el niño es exitoso el niño se
siente muy bien y al sentirse muy bien
se van a generar el núcleo acumbens
genera nuevas conexiones genera una
diversidad de conexiones que son
importantísimas para continuar
aprendiendo
bien en otras cosas que hemos aprendido
a través de las neurociencias ya través
de conocer el cerebro mejor
hoy en día está muy de moda el
multitasking y algunas personas lo
consideran una maravilla ser multitud y
poder sentarse a estudiar viendo
televisión chateando y oyendo música
ese es el multitasking eso no es
efectivo miren lo que pasa y lo que se
ha estudiado con el multitouch
si usted ve televisión al tiempo que
está estudiando los conocimientos se van
a unos núcleos que ustedes están viendo
ahí de la base del cerebro no se van
hacia el hipocampo que es donde deberían
ir se va en un sitio donde no es
eficiente el conocimiento entonces está
probado que si usted estudia viendo
televisión pues las cosas los resultados
no son tan buenos
qué pasa con el coeficiente intelectual
del que tanto oímos hicieron un estudio
en los eeuu
y comenzaron a tratar de elevar el
coeficiente intelectual de sus
estudiantes y se introdujeron
computadores toda suerte de juegos
mejoraron la nutrición en los niños
e hicieron todos los esfuerzos por subir
20 puntos el coeficiente intelectual lo
lograron subir lo subieron 24 puntos
y que comenzó a ocurrir
los niños después de un tiempo
comenzaron a tener su ecoeficiente
intelectual muy elevado pero la
inteligencia emocional se fue para el
suelo qué pasó con esos niños eran mucho
más irritables agresivos solos tristes
jaime 1 pues los efectos que pueden
tener a veces utilizar herramientas
son cosas para tratar de subir un
coeficiente intelectual en una forma
pues medio artificial
pero entremos ya en el punto de la
resiliencia que es la resiliencia la
resiliencia la capacidad que tiene el
cerebro de enfrentar el estrés y las
situaciones adversas eso es la
resiliencia
miremos qué estructuras incluyen en la
resiliencia en la resiliencia hay tres
estructuras del cerebro que son
fundamentales la amígdala la corteza
prefrontal y el hipocampo el hipocampo
es el centro de la memoria el hipocampo
es el que se altera cuando uno tiene una
enfermedad de alzheimer
y la amígdala es un centro de la
inteligencia emocional fundamental
algunos lo consideran el cerebro del
cerebro
la amígdala capta las situaciones
adversas
carta las situaciones de emergencia sólo
están atracando si lo están violando si
está presentando está frente a una
tragedia la amígdala actúa
inmediatamente con miedo y con terror es
la manera cómo actúa la amígdala
resulta que el la corteza prefrontal que
es el asiento de la razón controlan la
ventana es decir si la amígdala se
expone a una tragedia a una situación
difícil a una situación muy adversa la
corteza cerebral prefrontal la silencia
a pasivo
tranquiliza
a veces que ocurre que la amígdala
secuestra la corteza prefrontal y se
dispara con terror temor susto y no
puede reaccionar y entonces que se
produce ansiedad miedo terror
entonces qué es lo que tenemos que hacer
tratar de que en situaciones difíciles
la amígdala sea controlada por la
corteza prefrontal esto es muy
importante que la corteza prefrontal
controle la amígdala que la silencia
porque si no pues va a entrar la persona
en ansiedad que se ha visto hay niños
que nacen con la amígdala hipertrofiada
es decir más grande de lo normal esos
niños muchas veces sufren de ansiedad
qué es el hipocampo el hipocampo es la
otra estructura fundamental
ustedes ven esos triangulitos ahí son
células absolutamente espectaculares
estas células reaccionan para guardar
información muy difícil por ejemplo si
usted está experimentando un terremoto o
un tsunami queda registrado en esas
células del hipocampo las células
especializadas para registrar
situaciones muy difíciles
recuerdos deja el hipocampo ahí el
hipocampo deja registra movimiento
registra sonidos
registra visión es decir si la persona
se expone a un terremoto esa persona se
va a cortar perfectamente el movimiento
de lo que suena de lo que ve y esa
memoria perdura en el hipocampo por
siempre
y se va a cortar la persona de ese
episodio todo el tiempo si yo me
pregunto usted qué hizo en su cumpleaños
en 1980 no se va a cortar de nada si
usted le pregunta usted que recuerda el
último terremoto que vivió se va a
cortar con todo el detalle con los
sonidos con las visiones con el
movimiento lo recuerda perfecto son
células especializadas en registrar
movimiento sonido todo
lo que se dice hoy científicamente es
que como fuera de bueno poder o no
borrar en sus malos recuerdos no hay
medicinas que lo borren no hay terapias
muchas veces que lo borren lo atenúan
pero el recuerdo está ahí si usted le
pregunta de una situación difícil mala
la va a recordar la corteza prefrontal
utilizando la resiliencia para tratar de
controlar la situación sin embargo la
situación queda y grabar
miren la resonancia magnética funcional
ese cerebro
qué están viendo amarillo y rojo
el cerebro de una persona resiliente
mire cómo se activa la región prefrontal
la persona residente tiene una actividad
importante de la corteza prefrontal es
decir está controlando la amígdala en
forma adecuada
medel al otro la otra resonancia
magnética funcional de la derecha
no tiene actividad de la corteza
prefrontal es decir este caso podría ser
ese en el cual la vista la secuestra la
región prefrontal y lleva a la persona a
la ansiedad
la innovación y la creatividad que es
algo que también quisiera uno
desarrollar en los niños que por ejemplo
en lugar de estar les enseñando la tabla
periódica que se les olvida en pocos
meses una cantidad de algebraicos los
dejarán pensar los dejarán innovar por
ejemplo el sin el niño usted cómo
describiría un elefante volando que
comenzará a presentar cosas mucho más
relajadas que hay que hacer hay que
silenciar la corteza prefrontal en ese
caso la corteza prefrontal hay que
frenarla un poquito para que la persona
pueda innovar y pueda
y ser más creativa por ejemplo las
personas con demencia frontotemporal en
las cuales se afecta el lóbulo frontal y
las células del lóbulo frontal esas
personas con demencia frontotemporal de
pronto desarrollan actividades
artísticas muy interesantes
bueno qué recomendaciones hay para ser
más resilientes sin lugar a duda pensar
positivo es importantísimo 1 todos los
días se debería hablar a su cerebro
estoy bien me va a ir bien soy optimista
las cosas me van a salir bien no voy a
tener problemas ese pensamiento positivo
continuo al cerebro es clave es muy
importante quizás es de lo más
importante para ser resiliente no
recuerde de los problemas del pasado
hay problemas del pasado que lo
traumatizan a uno y trata de traerlos al
presente no es conveniente hacer eso no
traiga cosas del pasado trata de
evitarlas
practique no evite situaciones que le
generan susto hay situaciones que le
generan aún a veces susto y entonces las
trata de evitar
no es conveniente tratarlas de vital es
bueno exponerse y acostumbrarse y tratar
las de controlar y practique la
meditación y el mindfulness
la meditación y el mindfulness son muy
importantes para el cerebro se ha
comprobado claramente que el cerebro
cambia inclusive la corteza cerebral
cambia con la meditación y con el
mindfulness uno durante un día de
trabajo por ejemplo
no se concentren lo que está haciendo
tiene un 47% el tiempo pensando en otras
cosas diferentes y las cosas diferentes
pueden ser pensamientos negativos
entonces lograr practicar mindfulness o
lograr practicar meditación sin lugar a
duda va a ayudar a que las personas sean
más resilientes
miren este experimento que llevó a cabo
dalai lama lo llamaron de un centro
neurocientífico importantísimo en eeuu y
le dijeron dalailama queremos que nos
preste unos monjes que hagan meditación
porque queremos ver la resonancia
magnética funcional cómo funciona como
cómo se comporta él dijo no no me parece
que debemos verlos las personas que
hacen meditación a mí me gustaría hacer
resonancia magnética funcional en mis
monjes que son las compasivos quisiera
hacer resonancia magnética funcional
entonces que hizo hizo resonancia
magnética funcional un estudio grande la
llama y neurocientíficos en eeuu y miren
lo que se alumbra acá y se alumbra el
lóbulo frontal la región prefrontal se
alumbra
el núcleo acumbens el núcleo de la
recompensa el que estábamos hablando de
la comida y de la música con la
compasión se activa el núcleo accumbens
y esto comienza a darle uno un
significado del porque la gente feliz es
aquella que es grata aquella que es
compasiva aquella que es generosa que es
altruista no es la persona que tiene más
plata ni es la persona que tiene más
poder ni la que más influye en la gente
es la persona compasiva la persona
generosa la persona altruista
es lo que tenemos que hacer el cerebro
va a cambiar la tecnología va a avanzar
pero qué es lo que queremos hacer
en un futuro lograr personas más
compasivas más generosas más gratas
y que lleguen a ser mucho más humanos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]